foreign
[Music]
hey welcome back to stylecraft now I'm
going to show you an example of using
alignment uh in the real world so what
I'm going to do is I'm actually going to
take what I gave you guys as an optional
exercise a couple weeks ago which was
building the movie poster with all the
typography in the photo and I'll show
you how I would approach that if I was
challenged to do that so the first thing
I've got here is a composition I asked
you to do 3840 by 2160 so I'll click ok
and I've decided to work with this image
I'll give you a few different ones to
choose but I'm going to start with this
one and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to turn on my
rule of thirds
just like so
and I'm going to scale this image down a
little
bit
so what makes this image interesting is
that
um I could position
probably position the landscape down
here and this lower third with this
person being my center of attention
right here in this quadrant or I could
move everything up
and position this person up in here and
then because we're going to Black and
negative space I can leave this all
black down here it looks like it's part
of the ground so that's two different
ways I could approach it I'm actually
going to start
with
this person down here the landscape down
here and maybe make my topography the
center of focus in here
so next thing I need to do is I need to
bring in the type that we're going to
use
I'm just going to bring in each line of
copy as its own separate element one
separate layer here in my composition
but the first one was Stacy white and
I'm just going to start with helvetica
regular as my typeface and font of
choice so now I'm going to copy and
paste the rest of the type in and then
I'll pick back up when I've done that
okay so now I've got all my copy in here
I've got 11 lines of copy and my photo
here at the bottom which I'm just going
to lock that and I'm just going to start
with by turning off these layers of copy
and my first two pieces of copy are
going to be a cad Academy Award winner
and Stacy white so the first thing I
want to do is I want to
um get some contrast here
to Academy Award winner so I'm going to
drop that
oh maybe not even maybe I'll do half of
the original so let's go even more let's
go
let's break the rules here a little bit
let's just go small like that and
instead of regular let's go light
and I'm just nudging this with my
keyframes with my arrow key
and this is a great example already of
um visual
alignment because these are both left
aligned with the paragraph
and they're also if I click my align
button they're both left aligned
well there we go right there but you can
see
that the a is further out than the S
right
and it just looks visually off so here I
would take my arrow key
bring it in closer
bring it over further left something
like maybe in there it looks pretty good
to me
and then next I'm going to do the same
thing I'm going to turn on
Academy Award nominee
and let's just see what size this was
set to 35 which it still feels a little
bit big so let's go to 30.
and then we'll change this one to 30 as
well
we'll make it light
as well and then below that one we'll go
wrong
[Music]
and
again Academy Award nominees let's move
over a little bit here
and let's bring these up so everything's
left aligned here and you know what I'm
going to do I'm going to go ahead and
bring in I'm going to turn on
my rulers so I can easily click and drag
and pull out a guide here
and there's a guide
and you can see that the a is not lining
up right here with this line
go and turn this off
the S is the a is not quite
and this helps a little bit but you know
right in there it feels okay to me
this spacing still feels a little bit
too much this feels a little bit too
tight
I'm going to select both of these bring
them over
something about like that
and then let's see here
so the next we've got Douglas and we're
going to bring the Douglas down here
and we're going to bring them over and
snap them into place here
something like that and you know I'm
looking at this and it's still it's
feeling too
maybe too big
I think that maybe the first name could
be half the size and the second name is
how it is so let's just to explain to
you what I'm thinking here let me go
back to Stacy why let me turn these off
and I'm going to delete the space hit
enter on the keyboard and I'm going to
make Stacy half the size of 90 which is
45.
and then we're going to go back up into
Academy Award winner here and let's just
make it half of 45 will be 22.5
something like that
I'm also going to bring up
flooding here
I'm going to bring everything up
so
I want to do to give this a little bit
more prominence is I want to make
everything capitalized
and I'm going to decrease letting even
more
and let's make this even smaller let's
go maybe 18.
and let's just zoom out here and let's
just take a look at how this looks
with the image back on
I'm going to go ahead and drop Academy
Award winner
down here and just see how this looks or
maybe even
somewhere over in here
no I don't like that
just want to undo that
bring it back up there and let's go even
smaller let's go down to like
foreign
it's getting closer
and remember this isn't for uh video so
you know having smaller type like that
actually works in the case of a poster
and let's go ahead and make these bold
so now what I would do is I would
actually copy
these two lines I would duplicate them
bring them up here and then I would
change Stacy white to
Ron
Peterman
and Ron is not a winner he is just a
nominee so we need to change winner
just noticed is that because we've
capitalized
Stacy I do feel like we should have
capitalized Academy Award winner so
let's go ahead and do that
Academy
Award winner
yeah that works a little bit better
and we'll do Academy Award nominee
for Ron and we're gonna go ahead and
bring Academy Award
nominee for Ron just right down in here
and I'm going to delete those two and
then we're gonna use Douglas he's our
last actor let's capitalize him to
Douglas
roomy
and he needs to be bold as well
so you can see I aligned Douglas here to
the bottom edge of this proportion
proportional grid
and I'm going to give these
a little bit more spacing here let's
just back out and see how that looks
maybe up a little bit more
these can go up a little bit more
and now I'm just kind of looking at the
spacing between these two and these two
it looks pretty good
maybe just a little bit less spacing
there
yeah looks pretty good
next we've got the tag line which we'll
go ahead and capitalize that as well
that'll be the missing
dimension
I'll go ahead and drag that guy down
maybe that's light
and then
I'm sorry that's the title so that
should be bold
and then for the tagline a lot can
happen in the middle of nowhere so we'll
go ahead and drag that down as well
a lot can happen
in the middle
of nowhere
that will be light
and we'll do half the size because we do
want to be able to read that still and
then the missing dimension
I feel like should be quite a bit bigger
and what I'm doing here is since we're
in the center now we're vertically
aligned in the center of this
grid box and then here's the center
of our entire composition right here
roughly right here so what I'm doing is
I'm scaling up so maybe the n
kind of ends up about in the center
somewhere in there
and if I turn off the proportional grid
so it's starting to really come together
now it's starting to really look
interesting to me I'm gonna go ahead and
save this
so let's turn the grid back on
because the next we need to have
oscar-winning director and Stephen
Sondheim
so let's go ahead and bring these down
and we're going to make those we'll keep
those regular
this is 130 so maybe this could be
100
15. let's try 115.
that feels too big maybe a hundred
and I almost want to see this back to
regular as well
so that's set to 45 so what if this was
set to 45 as well that regular
oh I think we need a little bit more
prominence there so maybe 65
and I'm going to go ahead and add from
let's make that all caps from
Oscar winning
director
and that feels too big maybe it's 50.
let's get a little bit of space here and
the next one will be
and we'll zoom in here
and I think it'd be really interesting
to make his name slightly different than
the title here
so this is regular 50
. so maybe we change this to
60
75
maybe it's back to 90.
Soh so I don't remember how I forget how
to spell this s o h n h e i m
and this is just Stephen
and I'm gonna try and make this guy bold
so what I don't like about this is I
feel like the missing Dimension should
be the focus and now Sondheim is taking
over here so we need to shrink
everything down even more
so let's take this back down to what was
this let's make this
we'll make this even smaller
and we'll make this one let's go 60.
and it's okay if this type breaks this
line we don't have to keep everything
contained right you can see there's a
problem right here this is moving too
far left
and I'm looking at the spacing between
Oscar and winning and winning a director
and I want to get that close when we go
into Stephen Sondheim even though his
name is bigger
now it feels a little bit too
disconnected vertically
so maybe somewhere in here
maybe maybe we'll try and keep it
I don't want that to happen we're going
to shrink the distance here
go back to light
thank you
go back to regular
maybe just a little bit smaller
that's looking pretty good
now I feel like the whole thing needs to
move up just slightly in the frame
so we'll do that
we're gonna Center vertically Center the
whole chunk here and I'm just eyeballing
this
looks pretty cool
okay so the last two things we have here
is a B-52 production which we'll bring
down here
we're going to capitalize production
[Music]
and I want to make B52 I want to bold
that
so it really stands out
and we're going to make these light
foreign
and then overall this is way too big so
we'll go down to 45
[Music]
maybe 65
and then the last thing we have here is
the date
and the date I actually almost want to
see something totally different like
maybe it's
I'm just trying things here I don't like
that
so maybe I'll say coming
soon
and what was size this was a 65 so we'll
do coming soon
65 as well
and then we'll bold
the date
and a B-52 production
I feel like coming soon is competing
with it so we're actually going to be
coming soon bigger we'll go to 90.
so now I feel like these this typography
here needs to be
vertically aligned to this
right there so we look at this this is
uh vertically aligned to the bottom line
This is centered so let's bring this up
to the top
right there let's turn off our grid
go ahead and take off coming soon
yeah and that works for me I think that
that does a very nice job I could always
improve on this and keep working with it
but this is a great use of using a
proportional grid with alignment to
create a movie poster that works for
about any
type of poster so that's what I got for
you today hopefully uh you guys learned
something by watching me do this uh
leave a comment leave a question below
let me know what you think if you have
questions about anything I'm happy to
answer them anytime until next time
I'm Cameron and you're watching
stylecraft see you later